this is the third in a series of videos
that are designed to help independent
learners engage in self-directed study
of important and influential
philosophical authors texts and
movements this one focuses on a very
important school of ancient philosophy
that still has adherents today and that
is stoicism so I'm going to be talking a
lot about different stoic authors that
you might read and how you can approach
them and what you want to be attentive
to and what you don't need to actually
worry about since I know there's people
who get quite concerned about about some
things and that can sometimes be an
impediment holding them back from
studying it we're going to talk about
approaches that you can take and a whole
bunch of other things as well
now the Stoics are so important you use
a little bit fortuitous here but you can
notice on the bookshelf behind me a
whole bunch of literature secondary
literature mostly of stoicism I'll be
pulling some of these left the Shelf as
we we talk about what what you need to
be paying attention to in this video
particularly when we're looking at
translations and texts the Stoics are
quite important we're going to talk
about that in just a minute why you
should study them they're also rather
challenging so you want to have a few
things in mind as you're approaching
them and with any independent study I
think there's a few things that that go
across the board for any philosopher
that you're going to read so we'll talk
about those aspects as well
a preliminary question that really does
deserve an answer is why should we study
the Stoics in the first place and in
order to answer that question we really
need to ask another question who are the
Stoics and when it comes down to it most
of what you would be studying would in
fact be people who are part of what we
call the late stoah or the sometimes
they call it the Roman stoah three
thinkers in particular Seneca Epictetus
and Marcus Aurelius those are the people
that you'd encounter at the start there
were many other Stoics beat before them
and we'll talk about that in just a
minute but why should you study these
three thinkers in particular well they
are representatives of a very important
school of ancient Greek and then it
spreads to of course to the Roman domain
as well
philosophy stoicism in its time was
really one of the big contenders we
often treat philosophy as if it's well
it's Plato and there's the pre-socratics
before them and then there's Aristotle
and then there's all this Hellenistic
stuff and we we kind of push it to the
side and they were mostly concerned with
like you know ethics and philosophy of
life but they were kind of a decline and
that's actually a wrongheaded view on
philosophy but unfortunately one that
many of the histories of philosophy of
the 19th and 20th centuries push as a
narrative narrative that turns out to be
false when you start going to the text
so the Stoics were massively influential
in their own time you find the
Aristotelian Xand platanus and eclectic
and and skeptics and Epicureans and
other people all engaging with the
Stoics that's something that tells you
that their philosophy really mattered
they have a lot to offer as we're gonna
talk about just on their own and they
continued to play an important role in
influencing not only philosophy but but
culture more broadly long after the
school ceased to exist as an independent
school so you
a number of different practices and
insights from stoicism sometimes actual
texts like epictetus says and karidian
got absorbed into christian thought
throughout the Middle Ages and once the
Stoics were sort of rediscovered as such
in the Renaissance and then onward into
the modern period they were really
engaged you're gonna find thinkers like
Descartes drawing upon stoic thought and
and having Princess Elizabeth you know
actually read Seneca with him and
discuss Seneca you're gonna find David
Hume discussing the Stoics as a possible
you know philosophical way of life in
his own time a philosophical approach we
could go on and on and on it's really
only in the 19th and 20th centuries that
you get this this take that the Stoics
along with the Epicureans and skeptics
and also the Neoplatonic really don't
matter that much in their own time they
were among the you know most popular
schools and it's quite interesting too
if you think about it once you start
reading them they're very rigorous about
things so why would the why would they
be popular why would they capture the
imagination and the allegiances of so
many people well because there's a lot
there in stoic philosophy to study so
another key point that I want to bring
up and you're gonna see this
particularly when you read Seneca when
you read Epictetus perhaps a little bit
less with marcus aurelius and you're
also going to see this when you read
somebody like Cicero that stoicism
itself is quite a complex developmental
philosophy full of all sorts of very
interesting ideas and and you know
propositions about what you might do
there's some great arguments there
there's lots of interesting distinctions
there's there's a ton of things to sink
your teeth into and it's grounded on you
might say dealing with life trying to
make sense out of all the things that
other Four
officers are concerned with so it's well
worth reading for that by studying the
Stoics you're going to be introduced to
some additional new perspectives and
ideas and distinctions and problems
within philosophy things that you want
to try to wrap your head around not only
because they were influential and taken
up by other authors later on but also
because these are worth studying in
their own right and with the Stoics I
think there's an additional impetus and
this may be the first one for many
people
modern stoicism has become a sort of a
going concern there are hundreds of
thousands of people now who use stoic
philosophy in one way or another and and
with varying degrees of accuracy and
depth but they use it to make sense out
of their life their decisions their
personal development their workplaces
their relationships and so you know if
stoicism always was a philosophy as a
way of life kind of approach it really
is so in the present and I think that's
another reason why it's worth knowing
something about stoicism and it's really
important to know something about
authentic stoicism not just to read a
few popular texts or blog entries which
might be completely wrong about what
some what stoicism is actually preaching
so those are reasons why I think it's
worthwhile to dig into stoicism
one of the questions that I always get
asked by people engaging in
self-directed study is what editions and
what translations of the core texts do I
need to have and often lying behind that
is a concern about getting it right that
I'd like to say a little bit about
there's a number of different
translations for most important authors
who wrote in something other than
English and you're not going to lead
yourself astray unless you make the
mistake of thinking that the translation
is exactly the same thing as the
original text you're not going to damage
your mind or you know start off on the
wrong foot if you have a translation
that's not completely contemporary or
one that you even struggle with because
of the way that the the translator
decided to render certain terms you
should expect you're going to read and
reread and reread anyway and I'm going
to come back to that point later it's
often good if you can't read the
original language to consult several
different translations when it comes to
the Stoics there are a number of
different translations for every one of
the main authors out there going back
you know quite aways some of them
several centuries in English and those
can be a bit difficult but even the very
contemporary modern translations are
often challenging as well so you don't
have to put any pressure on yourself
that you have to get the right
translation or the right text because
there isn't any I'm gonna talk to you a
little bit about you know what sort of
texts and translations you might want to
have and you notice I'm holding these
books in my hand this is epictetus in
the Loeb Edition which is the old father
translation a rather old translation
it's two volumes
you know his four books and what's
really cool about this other than the
fact that you can see I take a lot of
notes is the fact that what you have
here is Greek on one side and English on
the other not very helpful I think for
readers who can't read Greek write an
epic Yunus by the way wrote in Koine not
in attic Greek
you know a person his time you can just
as well get something like this this is
the everyman edition of epictetus
discourses handbook or enchiridion and
fragments which by the way the lobe
contains as well
and it's you know it's it's a good
enough translation it's it's not
necessarily great at every point but
that that's in part because it's
difficult to translate somebody like
epictetus and this you can get fairly
cheaply um there's a number of different
translations of Epictetus out there i
can't say that you know any of them are
really terrible but i can't say that any
of them are perfect that's cuz i'm a
translator myself the key is to find
something that's going to work for you
and Epictetus if you're gonna study
stoicism is definitely somebody who
you're going to spend time with seneca
another great example here's two common
translations of his letters this one is
the the GU mir translation which is not
bad a little bit dated the the really
nice thing about this is how cheap it is
we actually use this in our stoic
fellowship meetings so that we're
literally all on the same page if you
want to invest a little bit of money you
might get a more contemporary
translation including this one by graver
and long two very important scholars and
translators when it comes to solar
system and this is University of Chicago
Press these are very recent quite good
there's other Seneca books in the same
series that you might check out I've
left a couple of them on the shelf but
here's one that includes various works
of his that have to do with hardship and
happiness they're organized according to
the theme so you know those are those
are nice to have I'll mention as well a
few other works that you're probably
going to want to find all of which are
fairly inexpensive there's you know
Cicero Cicero is available in the lobe
there's a lot of translations of Cicero
I do think that these cambridge texts in
the history of political thought or in
the history of philosophy are quite nice
I've got you know on duties and the on
moral ends here quite good but there's a
number of other translations of Cicero
available areas didymus is epitome of
stoic ethics Greek on facing page this
is this is a work that you'll want
somewhere down the line and then there's
this here achlys the stoic elements of
ethics fragments and excerpts mostly a
book full of notes the the actual
translation is fairly short and again
you know Greek on on facing page so
don't allow yourself to get too bogged
down and worrying about having the right
translation can be nice actually as I
said to have multiple translations so
you can compare and contrast them you
know I read the Latin but I you know
spend a lot of time reading these two
translations in Seneca and if I see
something that seems kind of off or you
know there's a big divergence well then
I'm back in the Latin checking it out
but that's not necessary for you to do
all of the time
try to find something that that really
works well for you something that you
can you know when you're reading it you
can get something out of it you can walk
away from that and say I understand this
and realize as I'm as I mentioned before
you're gonna have to read and reread
this stuff multiple times in part
because there are a lot of stoic terms
that are a bit difficult to translate
effectively so I'm gonna say a few
things about about those and some of
these would go for other Greek and Latin
terms that that you know other authors
or movements might use one thing that's
really key is the notion of eudaimonia
or you know happiness sometimes
translated as flourishing there's no
really great translation for that Greek
term and and that's okay likewise
there's a number of other terms that the
Stoics themselves came up with like
indifference
and preferred and rejected indifference
if you read Cicero you're gonna find him
discussing how these ought to be
translated because Cicero himself was
somebody who is rendering stoic
philosophy from its Greek original into
a Latin form so there's a lot of things
we're understanding what's what's going
on it's gonna be a cumulative process on
your part the translations are not
designed to get in the way so don't
allow them to become a stumbling block
for yourself
another book and author focused question
that I get asked very early on when
people want to begin studying stoicism
is who do I have to start with and which
work and in what order should I be
reading these books and there's a
related question - which is maybe I'm
not really up to starting with the
original authors from ancient philosophy
Epictetus Seneca and Marcus Aurelius
maybe I should read you know a summary
written by a 20th or 21st century
philosopher more a more popular work and
by the way when it comes to that I think
no no don't deprive yourself of the
opportunity of grappling with real
philosophy head-on in its native habitat
rather than being given the guided tour
by somebody who might be leaving some
stuff out or might give you some wrong
impressions about things I mean if you
want to begin by by reading summaries
that that's okay I'm not gonna say that
it you know it's gonna ruin you or
anything like that but I do see a lot of
people arriving at the original text
afterwards and saying wow I didn't know
that this was here or man I got a
mistaken understanding of what was going
on in these thinkers because I read so
and so before that it's better to go
straight to the the originals I think so
where should you start well we have
three authors
sanika we have a lot of writings by
Seneca we have Epictetus we we have you
know some stuff by him the discourses
which are kind of long the enchiridion
and then some some fragments here and
they're not written by Epictetus by the
way but written by his student Arian and
then we have Marcus Aurelius was pretty
short meditations those are the three
authors that you should be starting with
and now where should you start in terms
of books a lot of people like to start
with irelia says meditations in part
because it's it's pretty accessible when
it's short and it's you know kind of
scattered in its emphasis you know he's
there it's divided into books which
would be you know core relative to what
we call chapters
these days and it kind of moves from
point to point to point so some people
like it for that reason
Aurelius is not looking at stoicism in a
systematic way but you can give you a
great you know sort of introduction to
it I think that along with reading are
aliases meditations you also definitely
want to read Epictetus is enchiridion
now that'll sometimes be called the
golden sayings or the handbook they all
mean the same thing they all refer to
this short very very short work that is
sort of a best hits list put together by
Arian who thought that the stuff that he
was putting in there you know kind of
gave you a condensation of Epictetus
doctrine it is a bit challenging or
Elias is also challenging but I think
most readers are up to making some sense
out of it particularly when you go over
it multiple times and you think about
what's what he's talking about in the
work and you start comparing these stoic
things to each other then we have Seneca
and you know Senecas letters are you
know a pretty big book right these these
letters on ethics or letters to lick
Ilyas and I think you could start by
reading a few of them they're available
online you can find them on you know
wiki texts and just pick a few of them
to get a flavor of what's going on there
and then eventually you're gonna want to
read through all of those letters there
is one other text by somebody who's not
a stoic who is from ancient times who I
think it would be worthwhile for you to
read early on in part cuz it's rather
short
it's called stoic paradoxes and it's by
Marcus Tullius Cicero who was an
eclectic philosopher he identified with
the academic school but he drew on the
Stoics quite a lot and so if you put
together you know selections from
Senecas letters to Luke Ilyas or you
might pick one of his you know shorter
works as well you know they're many of
them are available in these these other
texts you know a hardship and Happiness
for example
contains on the shortness of life or on
tranquility of mind on happy life those
are good places to start as well you put
together those and epictetus is on
karidian and Marcus Aurelius is
meditations and now you've got a good
starting point after that you're gonna
want to continue through you're
definitely going to need just to read
and plan to reread and reread epictetus
is discourses because the enchiridion is
just a sliver of what's in the
discourses and Epictetus is a very
important really central figure Marcus
Aurelius is drawing upon among others
Epictetus Seneca you're gonna probably
want to go on and read all the letters
to Luke Ilyas or the ethic you know the
letters on ethics if you like and
probably some of his other works as well
as a matter of fact if you have the time
why not read all of it if you can after
that or perhaps in addition to that
there are some other things that you're
going to want to read as well some are
summaries of stoic doctrine which will
help you out and one of those is this
arias didymus epitome of stoic ethics
arias himself was not a stoic he also
wrote her an epitome of peripatetic or
Aristotelian ethics as well but he does
give you a nice overview of what it is
that the Stoics in fact taught in their
schools and you know we've got no reason
to think that he's misrepresenting
anything
you'll also find similar discussions in
Diogenes later toises lives of the
philosophers book seven is entirely
devoted to the stoic school so that's
well worth reading and you're gonna find
similar discussions in Cicero now I've
mentioned Cicero's stoic paradoxes
already but if you really want to
understand stoicism and you want to
study it you want to read Cicero and you
know there's quite a few texts of his
that you want to read now you might say
well why would I want to read somebody
who's not himself a stoic Cicero's
under Stoics as well as Epicureans and
academic philosophers and he sort of you
know picks and chooses these I like this
stuff over here I reject this over here
and because so much of original early
stoic literature has been lost Cicero is
one of the people who gives us a good
insight into what's you know what was it
that the Stoics actually did teach as a
matter of fact he knew Marcus Cato who
is in one of his dialogues representing
the stoic position right and Cato was
was a a stoic philosopher who was also a
statesman who embodied the philosophy
and died as a stoic during the you know
the civil wars right so Cicero gives you
a lot of important works I mentioned the
stoic paradox is already that's well
worth checking out some of the other
texts that are particularly important
for understanding the stoic position if
you want to understand stoic ethics then
the most important Ciceronian works
would be on the ends book three of which
is devoted to the stoic system that in
the mouth of Cato book four is Cicero
attacking it of course on duties which
is drawing on Panay TS the middle stoic
thinker so he wrote a book on duties
Cicero thought he could do better and
he's presenting a lot of interesting
stoic stuff he's also talking about some
of the other stoic scull arcs and the
disagreements that they had with each
other on ethical issues so that's worth
checking out the Tusculum disputations
very important longer work discusses the
issue of you know whether we should fear
death or not discusses the emotions and
great detail and depth virtues and vices
all sorts of other interesting topics in
there if what you're looking for is
stoic conceptions of religion then you
probably also want to read
on the nature of the gods and you should
probably check out on divination sister
himself did not accept the stoic views
on divination or on you know determinism
but he presents them to us in a you know
reliable way so they're worth checking
out and then there's also a short
somewhat fragmentary discussion in on
faith that talks about the Stoics as
well if you're interested in stoic
epistemology you probably want to read
on the academics and there's other
things in Cicero's work scattered here
and there but I think that's plenty
already somebody else who I will mention
who's worth checking out and again you
can get it in this book is here achlys
these are you know translations and
actually this book is quite nice because
there's an introductory essay and and
notes the text as well but you get to
read the the somewhat fragmentary works
that we have by this guy here at Cleese
who is another important stoic figure
there's there's other you know works
that you could check out there's you
know a work of fragments of you know the
Stoics but I I don't know unless you
really want to become a scholar that's
probably not worth too much of the time
that you might spend on it if you want
to go further than that and I realize
I've already said quite a lot you could
read other ancient authors who take a
less positive attitude towards the
Stoics than Cicero does foremost among
them would be the middle plate inist
Plutarch Galen the medical author is
also well worth checking out
particularly and when it comes to the
emotions there's a lot of early
Christian authors who also talk about
the Stoics and interesting ways clement
of alexandria for example Justin Martyr
locked on theists talks about them a lot
and we learn some things by reading
these people I also want to mention
a few other things as well and here you
know it's probably good for me to take a
little bit of a side route and tell you
a bit about you know I've mentioned the
early Stoics and the late Stoics and the
middle Stoics so stoicism starts out
with this guy Zeno and unfortunately we
don't have any full text by Xena but we
know texts that he's supposed to have
written because they're cataloged in
Diogenes Laertes lives of the
philosophers that's one reason why I
think you should read that that work
likewise the the other you know school
arcs the people who are in charge of the
stoic school like his file his follower
clean face and then the third school are
cruciferous very important author and
then Diogenes and Auntie Potter
we don't have works by them we only have
fragments and allusions to them those
are all the early stoah right there
they're there in Athens then stoicism
spreads to other places and we get
middle Stoics like Penn 80s who I've
mentioned and also posted Onias again
unfortunately we don't have works by
them so it's hard to tell exactly what
they they thought or taught we may in
our lifetime be fortunate and some
scroll could be discovered somewhere but
that's unlikely one thing does need to
be said though about the relations of
the Stoics to other schools of
philosophy so stoicism is a Socratic
philosophy it comes in sort of
circuitous path from students of
Socrates who that had students of their
own and you know started schools
this guy's II know studies with Christ
the cynic but he also studies with
members of the Platonic Academy and the
Megerian school as well
still Poe and pull them all so he's kind
of putting things together in an
eclectic way as far as we can tell then
forging them into his own
new system you could find reading you
know what we have of the cynics
unfortunately most of their literature
is lost quite useful as well
Epictetus himself has a really long
discussion of the cynic in his his
discourses in a chapter that could be
read all by itself in some respect but
somebody else who you might want to
check out who you might get something
out of is another one of Socrates
students and that's Xenophon now
Xenophon also wrote platonic dialogues
as Plato did Xenophon's dialogues are
you know a different somewhat different
character of Socrates one that's closer
to what the Stoics were really into and
so you could read you know those
dialogues by Xenophon and that might be
helpful for understanding where somebody
like epictetus is coming from as well
Zeno himself is to postive shipwrecked
and then you know washed up on the shore
of Athens lost all of his money lost all
of his cargo he's in a books booksellers
stall and he's reading Xenophon x'
account of socrates and he says where
can I find somebody like this and that's
when the bookseller points out croc days
so reading about that you know Socrates
through Xenophon could be useful to you
but to go back to the start of all this
you know the big three that's where
you're beginning some of their shorter
works then read more of their stuff and
keep going back and forth and back and
forth then you know expand to Cicero and
maybe some Plutarch maybe some Galen
maybe some other authors you've got
those summaries the stoic doctrine that
can be quite useful and this way you can
get a really good conception of you know
what the stoic school is teaching and
you'll find it quite rewarding
I do have some advice for you that may
be helpful based on the author's
themselves and their styles and these
genres of the text that they're putting
in front of you so you know if we start
with the big three and we think about
Epictetus Seneca and marcus aurelius
let's let's start with elias first
because that's rather straightforward we
only have one book unless you want to
read you know books about Marcus
Aurelius or you want to read some of his
letters too pronto which are available
but if you're reading his meditations
what you're reading is a book that's
actually entitled to to himself right
it's a notebook of sorts that he carried
around with himself and wrote things as
sort of reminders and so don't look at
it as a text book in which Marcus is
speaking directly to a student telling
you about what stoicism is it's more for
somebody who already has a good
grounding in stoicism who's writing
little reminders to himself or working
out some thoughts now of course that
doesn't mean that you can't learn a lot
about stoicism from it not least because
Marcus is a pretty you know interesting
stylist and an author and he's a deep
thinker as well and also somebody who's
a leader of the world at the time you
know the the Roman Empire was a
significant portion of civilization what
you shouldn't expect in Marcus Aurelius
is for all of the passages to line up in
some sort of systematic way he's not
doing something like that so you have to
do a bit of correlation you know I I do
work for example on anger and he talks
about anger at a number of different
points on the work but he never has like
a section that is the definitive take on
anger you've got to do some correlation
back and forth you might want to make
notes to yourself or you know like I do
sometimes in my own books you can see
I've got all the like those Epictetus
discourses
book 1 you notice I use two different
things little post-it notes that stick
in the side and then a whole bunch of
bookmarks right you might want to do
something like that if you're trying to
understand particular areas let's talk
about Epictetus next so as I mentioned
the enchiridion kind of like a best hits
list if you like or a digest is another
way of putting it it's taking passages
and putting them together as chapters in
this thing that you could literally hold
in your hand the N in pay our hand ideon
little thing right and so it's not meant
to cover everything having to do with
stoic philosophy instead it's just meant
to again give you a bunch of very useful
reminders think of it as sort of a
starting point rather than the
definitive text if there is a definitive
text with epic with epictetus it is the
discourses and the discourses are quite
long and involved we think that we
probably have only half of the
discourses that arian actually wrote
unfortunately but at least we have F of
them because we could have none and that
would really suck they are organized
more or less according to topics but
again not everything on a given topic
will necessarily be worked out in
complete detail in that chapter and that
book so you do have to do a bit of
correlating I'll give you a one prime
example the Stoics talked about what we
call prolapses which means sort of
general conceptions that we have of
things they sometimes translators
preconceptions it's discussed at a
couple points in book one and at other
points throughout the discourses and
you've got to put together sort of a
composit picture of that again when it
comes to Seneca much of what you're
reading are actually letters and
interestingly you know we know who the
letters are addressed to and they often
speak to us quite well but Seneca is
almost always taking into
account the person who is writing to so
for example when you when you read his
letters to Luke Ilyas you're gonna
notice him praising rather
uncharacteristically a rival school of
the Stoics the Epicureans
and even Epicurus himself but that's
because Luke Ilyas is himself somebody
interested in epicureanism he doesn't do
that in other places letters are not
intended to provide a comprehensive you
know this is the final word on things as
a matter of fact Seneca apologizes and
some of his letters for allowing them to
get too long and they tend to get longer
look the further we get into his
correspondence but that's that that's
that then Seneca also writes some things
that are more philosophical treatises
another thing that you might find
interesting Seneca also wrote plays and
you could consider those to be part of
the stoic corpus as well if you want to
read them so those are worth reading
Cicero is a bit of a tougher read
sometimes he writes things in the form
of philosophical Treaty sees he's
assuming an audience that's fairly
conversant with the things that he's
talking about it usually does provide
some introduction through the mouths of
his speakers but sometimes he doesn't
sometimes he just assumes that you you
understand it and Cicero also writes
dialogues now these are not always
dialogue dialogues where there's a lot
of back-and-forth you know what do you
think about this well I think this well
I think you're wrong about that point
quite often there there'll be long
periods in which page after page after
page one person is speaking and they're
presenting a point of view it might be
the stoic view on you know the gods and
the heavens and things like that and
whether you can prove that God exists
for example in book two of on the nature
of the gods or it might be the epicurean
point of view or it might be something
else might be criticisms but quite often
it's it's going to be a long discourse
and
Cicero will do a lot of explaining along
the way but it can be quite helpful to
have learned what some of these things
mean as well by reading the earlier
stoic thinkers here arc leaves
unfortunately a lot of the stuff that we
have by him is rather fragmentary and
what we do have is quite interesting
there's not that much to be said about
that area's didymus when you read his
epitome if you do read it you're gonna
find it's a little bit dry it's mostly a
bunch of you know here's what the Stoics
say about this and a whole bunch of
classifications but it's it's quite
useful and it's fairly short so that can
be quite good another thing to keep in
mind I would say when it comes to
reading these Stoics so the the original
early Stoics they did not give a lot of
attention to style rhetoric delivery
anything like that the people that were
getting to particularly Seneca and
Cicero have a real sense for that and so
they write in a way that you know the
style is structuring and the rhetorical
motifs are structuring what it is that
they're telling you Epictetus a little
bit less so but again it's not straight
Epictetus it's Aryan his his biographer
well a historian military person and an
epic penises recorder let's call him
right because it's not really giving us
a biography as such of epictetus he's
more presenting Epictetus speaking to us
but it's still filtered through Aryan as
well or Elias of course has studied all
of these these things and he's got a
good style and stuff so you do want to
be somewhat attentive to that as well
don't expect this is the last thing I'm
gonna say about about format don't
expect any of these books to provide you
in a completely systematic form
everything that the Stoics are teaching
because they had
access to the literature that we don't
have access to because it's been lost to
antiquity so you know you'll find Cicero
Seneca epictetus talking about you know
works by Chris tipis that that somebody
might have you know have talked about or
prided themselves on being able to
interpret Epictetus actually talks very
very explicitly about that it says don't
pride yourself on that pride yourself on
being able to apply it we don't have
that so in the background of all of this
is a systematic philosophy but it's not
being presented to you in a systematic
form in the writers that we have so you
do have to do a bit of correlating
things and interpreting and and this is
an iterative process that's not
something that you're gonna read all at
once and everything will fall into place
it's gonna take a lot of going back and
forth to to get a good sense of what it
is that the Stoics are actually putting
forth as their positions the very last
thing that I'll say is don't expect
complete agreement between all the
different stoic figures we know from for
example Cicero that there were
disagreements between some of the Skoll
arcs about about issues so epictetus
will not always say exactly the same
thing that Seneca is saying they won't
always use the same language either for
example in Seneca the virtues are really
front and center
you don't see epictetus talking about
that so much instead you see them
talking a lot more about what's in our
control what's not in our control the
roles that we have and mitigating
conflicts or contradictions so think of
these not as as contradicting each other
but as highlighting complementary
aspects of a common doctrine school and
way of life
if you go online and start looking for
secondary literature on the Stoics
you're gonna be confronted with a vast
secondary literature and you might not
really be sure where to start so I want
to say a few things about that
there is one other thing I need to say
right at the beginning which is that you
know since we do have a whole movement
that we call modern stoicism you can
look at some of the secondary literature
as in a certain way a kind of primary
literature as well of contemporary
stoicism and I would include things like
you know popular works or more applied
works like Massimo Pigliucci
how to be a stoic or Donal Robertson's
build your resilience Lawrence Becker's
new stoicism of course which I'll talk
about in a moment and a lot of other
things as well there there are people
who are practicing Stoics who are
contributing to the ongoing development
of stoicism I'll also put in a little
plug too for the stoicism today the the
blog that I added this is the set of
entries put together by the previous
editor Patrick oh sure
selected writings really great stuff by
people who are either interested in
stoicism or who are self-identifying as
Stoics on all sorts of things from
dinner parties to medicine to police
saying to dealing with grief you name it
so where might you begin I also do have
to give a few cautions that might be
helpful about secondary literature
there's a lot of literature out there
that mentions stoicism or involve
stoicism that's not particularly good so
let me start by talking about academic
takes on stoicism if you open a work and
you find that they're saying that
stoicism is just a retreat from reality
you know that it came about because of
the the
struction of the Greek city-states and
the loss of you know meaning or anything
like that
that's a nineteenth-century take on
stoicism that that's pretty much dead
wrong it doesn't really work well for
understanding stoic authors and usually
represents a misinterpretation of them
and this was quite common you know you
see figures like Nietzsche
getting the Stoics wrong basically
because they're not Nietzsche Hegel
getting the Stoics wrong
Bertrand Russell of course gets them
wrong and his history of philosophy and
then we go on and on and on about that
so you do want to be careful about that
and there are some people even in the
present quite often unfortunately
Aristotelian hsihu should know better
because they've been misinterpreted by
so many people who get the Stoics wrong
and so you don't want to waste time so
much on them you you also need to be
wary of popular literature on stoicism
that turns it into something that it's
not
stoicism is not a bunch of life hacks
it's not a way to you know do the Dale
Carnegie thing of making friends and
influencing people that may be a side
effect of it but that's not primarily
what it's all about there's a lot of
people who try to you know harness
stoicism to produce success in whatever
way that they they view it but they're
really they tend to be pretty
superficial in their approach to it and
they're not they're not really faithful
to stoicism and the Stoics would look at
them and say you've got some things
fundamentally wrong so that that's a bit
of a problem putting all of that stuff
aside let's talk about quality secondary
literature let's start with this book
right this is a very influential book by
Larry Becker and if you want to get it
go ahead I actually spent months leading
a client through this in part because
it's a very very difficult work people
who recommend this I think half of them
have not actually managed to read past
the
duction this is a you know top level
difficulty book I would say this is a
difficult as Heidegger or Hegel or you
know pick whoever else you find
particularly difficult it is a really
good book and it played in a very
important role in bringing about the you
know revival of stoicism but it's tough
other authors who are similarly
important in the revival of stoicism
that are approaching it more as
academics than as popular writers a long
really important person Chris Gill I
have a few other works here by people
that fit in there John Sellars Brad
Inwood Margaret graver has a just simply
excellent book on stoicism and emotion
but rather challenging again took
several months to work through that one
as well
with some clients and there's a number
of other you know
recent studies as well that are worth
checking out Brian Johnson's role ethics
of epictetus quite good this is my
Gretchen Radim shills the Roman Stoics
you know and we could go on and on and
on with all sorts of great secondary lit
book recommendations there's a lot of
great scholarship out there you want to
make sure that it's people who are
actually sympathetic to the Stoics and
not just trying to bash them and they're
not just trying to make a name for
themselves by saying that becoming a
stoic will make you you know in a sort
of Benjamin Franklin healthy wealthy and
wise sort of sort of thing as well I did
mention you know that there is also a
popular literature more applying
stoicism you know and I brought up
Massimo's how to be a stoic as an
example Dollar Robertson's build your
resilience there's lots of other things
Robertson and and actually piggley do
you have new books out as well this is
another interesting run by somebody who
wants to make stoicism as simple as
possible talk
Chakrapani his unshakeable freedom and
so there's a lot of secondary literature
that you can study I think that there's
nothing wrong with reading that stuff if
you want to begin with it that's
perfectly fine I think that you if you
really want to understand stoicism it's
always important to go back to the
source text so again there should be
sort of an iterative process where
you're reading Epictetus and then maybe
reading a work about Epictetus or a
piece about epictetus or an article and
then you go back and read some more
Epictetus first of all you know to get
back to epictetus but also to see if the
author gotta epictetus right and and if
there's anything that that that's
contributing to help you understand it
so I wouldn't worry too much at the
beginning about secondary literature
unless you really really feel that you
need that and then you know you can find
most of those works online or at local
libraries fortunately or you can order
them directly so that's that's pretty
much what I have to say about secondary
sources
one of the last things that I think I
need to talk about a bit is problems and
issues that you don't need to be
particularly concerned with but some
people really like to push and the
reason I bring this up is because for
some these can become stumbling blocks
or obstacles to actually putting in the
time to study the stoic texts and
thinkers they worry too much about these
these issues that will eventually work
themselves out in most cases by by doing
the study and then they don't do the
study so it's a bit of a chicken-egg
problem one of these right off the bat
is when you're studying philosophical
literature do not worry about whether
you buy into it whether you accept it
all that's not the measure for whether
you're making progress but the measure
is are you understanding it and
understanding is not the same thing as
agreement and it's not the same thing
even as appreciation you could find
Epictetus dry but you could find
epictetus incredibly valuable to study
you might not like Senecas style or you
might think he's off on some things that
he he was too you know willing to give
in to the Epicureans or something like
that that doesn't have to detract from
you actually studying Seneca so don't
worry about whether you buy in or not
another key thing is don't worry about
the fact that we don't have all the
stoic sources because you don't need to
have all of them in order to get a solid
understanding of what it is that the
Stoics we're teaching it could be that
will discover a long-lost manuscript by
xeno or cruciferous or or you know
Auntie Potter and that will really
change the way that we've used stoicism
more likely anything that we would find
would just reinforce what it is that we
already know about stoicism and
contribute a fuller picture so you don't
have to be too preoccupied with
the loss of probably clothes close to
90% of stoic literature you know you
also don't need to worry about whether
the Stoics have got Socrates right
there's a lot of back and forth in
internet forums about that sort of thing
I think that's really a side issue there
were multiple interpretations of
Socrates Plato's is one Stoics the
cynics the you know to renege school the
Euclidean it they're all different
viewpoints on one guy I don't think it's
that important of an issue to worry
about you do also don't have to get
drawn into these questions of is acts
whether acts as a person or a practice
stoic I think that's quite often a real
waste of time and again tends to lead
people away from actually learning about
what stoicism has to teach don't worry
about whether this current basketball
player or politician or you know this
this stance on a particular
controversial issue is stoic or not
figure out what stoicism is and then you
can tell others what this one thing is
stoic or not but people spend a lot of
time on that that sort of thing another
thing that I think is a bit of a
distraction is trying to say what is the
definition of stoicism or what is the
core idea of stoicism Seneca tells us
super clear and this is reinforced by a
patatas by Cicero by other people
stoicism is a complex network of key
ideas distinctions practices that a
person builds and and sort of
incorporates into their personality and
into their their mind so it's not going
to be reducible down to one idea like
the dichotomy of control or you know
just be virtuous or anything like that
people who tell you that are leading you
astray and they're you're not doing
yourself
by buying into them you don't have to
worry about them you don't have to
refute them but don't get caught in that
trap of saying I have to have not one
central idea because it's a network of
ideas that refer to and reinforce each
other so I think those are things that
that would be good to keep in mind
I do have a few final thoughts
and you might say encouragement for you
as a self-directed student one of these
is something that I say to my students
and classes but I say to many other
people if you have enough support and
you approach things in the right way
anybody can study philosophy that
doesn't mean that you're going to
understand everything right away or even
at the very end but that's not the
measure of whether you're doing a good
thing by studying a classic
philosophical school or thinker or text
you do the best that you can you use the
resources that you have there's a lot of
things available I've contributed some
but many other people have contributed a
lot of great resources to helping people
understand stoicism and you make
progress and that's the key thing do you
understand more of epictetus after
putting in a couple weeks than you did
before that if so good you can build
upon that same thing with Seneca same
thing with Cicero same thing with Marcus
relia same thing with any of these
figures don't get too drawn into
worrying about whether you know people
or other people have got stoicism
completely right those debates have been
going on forever posted Onias himself
took a lot of heat from his fellow
Stoics back in his own time for being
unorthodox in important ways but it's
posted onus that we know anything about
and not that you know the Schmucks who
are criticizing him at the time stoicism
is really a valuable school of
philosophy not not just for applying
stuff but to understand the world of
ideas just as important as Plato or
Aristotle probably more important than
the Epicureans another one of the big
schools of the time so I hope that this
encourages you and empowers you to dig
into the stoic texts and you know just
make as much progress as you can you're
gonna start to see all sorts of cool
correlations on issues between
the Stoics and other thinkers and within
the stoic school itself so good luck and
I hope you get yourself some stoic text
whether it's buying them online or
buying them in a bookstore getting them
from library or you know finding them
somewhere in somebody else's library and
get to it
you